j'espère
que sa passion favorite
une à 15h pour moi
de tourner cette page 7000 personnes
donc on témoigner devant cette
commission et parmi elles le député néo
démocrate roméo saganash lui-même un
survivant il a passé dix ans au
pensionnat anglican de la tuque en haute
mauricie et un de ses frères est mort
dans un de ces établissements en 1954 le
petit johnny n'avait que 6 ans je ne
m'en entretenir dans quelques instants
avec roméo saganash mais d'abord
j'aimerais qu'on écoute un extrait de
son témoignage devant la commission
c'était en avril 2013 mais bon je me
suis assis à ce jour ce qui est arrivé
réellement avec tueur niche à ce jour on
n'a pas de certificat de décès pour dire
niche et ça a pris 41 à ma mère pour mes
mains de trouver son petit
johnny ch était intérêt c'est les prix
quant à l'ondé pouvoir trouver le dieu
de ce matin jusqu'à ganache bonsoir
bonsoir scellé votre témoignage était
très émouvant pourquoi est-ce que
c'était important pour vous de raconter
publiquement ce qui s'est passé pendant
ces années de pensionnat
c'est toujours important de tourner des
pages comme comme celle-là c'est une
page une page très différente de la vie
et d'autre part je pense que c'est
important pour nous tous qui ont vécu
des expériences similaires de faire son
deuil de tout ça et le rapport de la
commission de vérité et de
réconciliation qui va être rendu public
demain est une autre étape
ça nous permet de de tourner la page de
le faire sonner de toutes ses textes ses
expériences atroce que nous avons vécu
et libérateur pour vous d'une certaine
façon le totalement totalement libre et
libérateur pour pour moi et beaucoup
d'autres j'en ai rencontré plusieurs ici
aujourd'hui à ottawa et il y attendent
avec impatience les conclusions les
recommandations surtout de la commission
justement cette commission ce rapport
qu'est ce que vous voulez quelqu'un qui
l'amène comme solution parce que ce sont
des solutions qu'on cherche maintenant
absolument est l'une des choses qu'il
faut se rappeler par ailleurs dans tout
ça est ce que ça va être le plus le
repas le plus important depuis le
rapport de la commission royale sur les
peuples autochtones qui a été rendue
publique en 1996 alors c'est un des plus
importants rapports sur les questions
autochtones depuis sept ans est presque
20 ans maintenant alors asseyons de
faire avec ce rapport
quelque chose de plus tangible depuis
concret n'est plus un manifeste parce
que la dernière fois on n'a pas fait
grand chose en termes d'actions après le
rapport là comme si royal donc c'est
important qu'on puisse prendre saisir
cette opportunité que nous aurons demain
et aller de l'avant ensemble et pas
juste des gouvernements et j bien les
gouvernements mais le public en général
aussi parce que on est tous là même
bateau dans ce pays ça concerne tous les
canadiens soit quand ça concerne tous
les canadiens je me rappellerai toujours
lorsque jack layton le regretté jack ma
de mardi une fois que j'ai été élu en
2011 est ce que tu veux être le porte
notre porte-parole de l'opposition à sur
les questions autochtones
j'ai dit non j'ai dit non parce qu'on
est très peu d'autochtones dans le
parlement actuel et pourquoi ce serait
le fardeau d un des rares autochtone au
parlement d'assumer vos erreurs passées
et de d'essayer de trouver des solutions
c'est un problème canadiens que nous
avons créé ce gâchis relève d'autres des
autochtones
alors il faut que ça il faut que ça se
fasse ensemble je suis là pour aider
je suis là pour assister suis là pour
conseiller bien sûr parce que fera aussi
sont les parlementaires qui ont vécu
dans les réserves qui ont vécu les
passionnants sur cette expérience de qui
ont trouvé de solution à certains
certains enjeux certains défis dans
certaines parties de ceux de ce canada
que nous connaissons magie dont la nord
du québec et je préfère ma part pour le
reste du canada mais on peut maintenant
dire qu'on connaît une partie de la
vérité on a entendu tous ces témoignages
mais pour ce qui est de la
réconciliation qu'est-ce qui va falloir
nous en parler mais qu'est-ce qui va
falloir qu'on fasse pour en arriver à un
début de réconciliation
justement c'est ça qui est important il
faut des gestes concrets et maintenant
un mois j'ai beaucoup de misère à voir
des excuses de la part du premier
ministre en 2008
et quand je sais très bien que d'autre
part il a continué
à travailler annie et droits
fondamentaux des peuples autochtones
seul homme même acquis et s'est excusé
alors ça ne marche pas comme ça des
excuses je pense qu'il faut passer à
l'action et la juge en chef de la cour
suprême du canada
les mclaren qui a parlé qu'à utiliser
les mots très lourd de sens elle a parlé
de génocide culturel
est ce que c'est important que ces mots
là se retrouvent demain dans ce rapport
je pense que la juge en chef de la cour
suprême
c'était important que que ces mots
viennent d'elles a exprimé tout
simplement ce qui est déjà prévue par le
droit international par rapport aux jets
génocide
la convention internationale sur le
génocide parle dans son article 2
paragraphe eu exactement ce qu'on a fait
aux enfants autochtones pendant 140 ans
au pays alors que je pense que l'exprimé
tout simplement ce qui était la loi
internationale
par rapport à tout ça par ailleurs la
loi forçant le rapport s il faut que
justin clairet âge je mentionnerai aussi
que dans le droit interne et soeurs ya
pas de qualificatif de génocide culturel
si je décide tout court la définition
très claire à cet égard et j'espère que
compte que la commune elle la commission
reconnaître que c'est ce qui s'est passé
et qu'on puisse aussi avoir une fois
avoir dit cette vérité corpus passer à
autre chose et des choses puis coca et
pourquoi ce serait important pour mener
justement la réconciliation interminable
ce saganash ce mot l'utilisation de ces
mots là mais je pense qu'il faut se dire
les vraies choses
d'ailleurs les mots en parlant de mots
que différents rapports de par le passé
sont très importants cet égard les mots
qu'ils ont utilisé les autorités john
mcdonough a pensé à tout des activités
des ministres du mi16 affaires indiennes
de l'époque et mots qu'ils ont utilisés
c'est justement ça tu es l'indien dans
chaque enfant
qu'on kidnappe en vertu de ce système de
passionnant c'est les mots qu'ils ont
utilisés pour moi qui les expriment
aujourd'hui ils ont dit on doit tuer
l'indien dans chaque enfant qu'on
kidnappe partir de ce système
alors c'est eux qui leur dit c'est pas
moi les mots sont importants alors on
surveillera avec beaucoup d'intérêt le
dépôt de ce rapport de ma merci beaucoup
et c'est saganash los héros
il pourra en apprendre davantage sur
cette page très sombre de l'histoire du
canada je vous invite à consulter notre
dossier web à l'adresse que vous voyez à
l'écran